hi there today I thought we would be
looking at growing neural cellular
automata which is an article on the
still dot pub which I found pretty neat
so this is kind of an interactive
article if you don't know this still dot
pop check it out
it is a cool new concept as an
alternative to the classical journals or
the the conference system so what allows
you to do is to kind of write articles
that are a bit more interactive a bit
more in like engaging and don't have the
there's no PDS there's no pages there
animations and so on so I think we'd be
looking at this article today which is
kind of growing those neural cellular
automata so if you don't know what
cellular automata are this is a very
kind of old concept the most famous one
is called the game of life where you
have these cells here you can see every
pixel is a cell and they follow some
kind of update rule and usually it's the
update rule something like if my
neighbor is alive I'm going to be alive
as well in the next time step and if or
if enough neighbors are alive and if
only there are few neighbors are alive
I'm going to die so this gives rise to
these kind of patterns and the air is
the same is done with color and the
update rules are a bit more complicated
so basically here traveler oh nice ok so
in the game of life if you play it the
the most prestigious thing to get is are
these kind of travelers I have not this
is the first time I've managed to do
this in this thing so what does it do so
each pixel here is kind of an autonomous
thing that is only allowed to look at
its neighbors in order to decide whether
or not in the next time step it is going
to be alive look it's like incorporating
again
so so each each cell looks at its
neighbors and then decides what its next
state will be and here it's not only
alive or dead
that would be white and the live would
be anything else but it is also I guess
this white isn't it is also the color so
that each cell decides on what color it
should have and then this is a live
thing so it kind of reproduces right you
can see if I start it new if you double
click here it grows from somewhere else
and this is completely local so these
cells really only look at their
neighbors that's the special part right
they don't look at the global structure
it's not like again that can look at the
entire picture and decide what what's
still missing what this can also do if
you destroy part of it they can kind of
grow back just again just out of local
update rules of the level of the
individual cells and their neighbors
they're trying to do these big
structures so let's look at how they do
it so basically here's how they model a
cell and let's go over here so each cell
as I said is made up of 16 channels and
here it's modeled as 3 by 3 but I think
each cell is really one pixel and each
cell is allowed to look at its 8
neighbors right so each cell is allowed
to look at its 8 neighbors across 16
different channels and the 16 channels
here mean the first three are RGB so
this is the actual color that is seen
then there is an alive or dead Channel
so and what they call an alpha Channel
so if this channel is high the cell is
considered alive otherwise it is
considered dead and not part of the
pattern so a cell can come alive or die
depending on its neighbors and then the
rest the rest 12 channels are what they
call hidden channels so the cell is
allowed to encode some Hades
there so there's each cell is
represented by the 16 dimensional vector
which is not much right
and then each cell is allowed to look at
three things so from the bottom here
it's allowed to look at its own state so
at its own 16 dimensional vectors and it
is allowed to look at its neighbors and
it does this by doing a convolution with
a soap oil filter and the sobel filter
is simply a fixed filter that you do a
3x3 convolution with as you can see here
is basically a gradient filter so it
basically measures the difference
between what's to the left of the cell
and what's to the right of the cell and
here in the southern y-direction the
same in the y-direction so it's
basically allowed to look at gradients
in states of its neighbors this is
modeled after real cells kind of looking
at chemical gradients in their
neighborhoods so and this is all this
this is all that the cell has to decide
what it's supposed to do next right and
what we want is we want that each
individual cell only looking in its
neighbors produces in total they will
produce this kind of a very complex
pattern so the updated rule is the
following you convolute with the sample
filters and you take the cell identity
you put this all into a vector you put
it through a very very small neural
network so this is one dense layer one
relu and then another dense layer to get
the next 16 dimensional vector which is
the next state and that defines your
update rules that doesn't really define
the next state that defines the Delta to
the next state kind of like a residual
neural network so basically which cells
need to come alive in the next time step
which cells need to die and how are they
to change their colors right and then
you get the output of the next step
right so that's that's basically the
entire thing so all that is learned here
is the the update rule of the neural net
right so basically the neural network
decides it looks at a cell and its
neighbors and decides what the
information in the cell in the next step
should be right and you do this for
multiple time steps let's I want
actually want to go down here you do
this for multiple time steps the initial
state is simply one cell that is alive
here in the middle everything else is
dead this cell is alive and black you do
this from many steps right and then at
some point you get an output and you
compare the output to your desired
output you compute a loss that is
differentiable and because your update
rule is differentiable and your loss is
differentiable you can backprop through
time to the original to the original
pattern here and you can basically learn
this update rule by back dropping
through time this is a bit like an LS TM
and if you see in the architecture here
I think this residual connection is
really the key to making this work over
time because usually I would not expect
something like this to easily emerge
over time because you have the problem
of vanishing and exploding gradients and
you have no way of mitigating this
problem here in this simple neural
network but in case they backprop
through time here so each of these
update steps which again this isn't this
isn't one neural network with many
layers this is the same neural network
applied over and over and over and over
again and then there is a loss computed
so basically the gradients will
accumulate over these steps basically
tell the network what it needs to adjust
to go from this one single block pixel
to this final desired state if you do
this over and over again you learn
things you learn a update rule that will
give rise to that pattern hopefully now
here is a kind of an illustration of
this alive and dead thing so what they
do is they consider cells that have an
alpha channel and said this one of these
channels called
for they have an alpha channel above 0.1
it's considered a live right and part of
the of the loss then the neighbors the
neighbors of these cells that are below
0.1 but our neighboring a cell that is
mature alive they they're called growing
they're also part of the loss right so
simply by being close to something
someone that is alive a cell that is
alive you are considered alive as well
but your neighbors aren't right he likes
only the neighbors of really alive so
there's a really alive kind of alive and
then there is dead and dead the the
meaning of dead here at the gray ones is
that they're not they won't become part
of the pattern part of the loss right
they're dead alright so what will this
get you initially so here is an
animation if they train this just like
that just backdrop through time with a
target pattern and then they let it run
you see these patterns actually emerge
so that's pretty cool but then if you
let them run for a longer than they've
been trained
you basically have no guarantees on
what's going to happen like these update
rules were simply trained to achieve the
pattern within a certain number of steps
right if you run for more than that and
apply the update rules for longer than
that you you have like there's little
like you have no guarantee you what's
going to happen these update rules will
simply continue as you can see here and
produce some weird stuff so they are
trying to fix this so what they do is
basically they train for a longer but
they do it in a kind of different way so
at each at each step of training and as
a step I mean a batch over these number
of time steps so so they the sample a
batch initially it's just all black
pixels right as we see how evolved and
then they um optimize for these number
of time steps and then
at the end so what they do is they don't
always start from the back pixel but
sometimes they also start from a
previously seen in the state so
basically they take the end state of a
previous training run and then they just
continue from that instead of starting
from the initial point and you see after
some training they get better and better
so initially you see the thing on the
left here the thing on the left here
being a starting state and then it
progressively gets better so basically
by starting from end states of other
things you learn to so if the end state
of the other thing isn't very good you
basically learn to go to the good
pattern to that pattern you want but of
course over time there's going to be
more and more of these end States that
you train from that are already pretty
close to the pattern you want and so
then what that means is you learn to
reproduce the pattern so you are already
at a good point you learn to stay at
that good point and then that enables
you to basically learn update rules that
if you're not at the pattern you want
they go towards the pattern you want but
also if you run for longer if you are
already are at the pattern you want then
you stay at the pattern you want so
that's what we basically saw in the very
initial demonstration where you could
this is a live demonstration like this
thing up here this is alive this is
running right and you see the update
rules stated they are continuously
applied they basically stay at the
pattern where they are and that is also
that is learned because of this protocol
that you train from end states as well
as from beginning states so the next
thing is what I'm doing here is I can
destroy part of the pattern and it will
kind of regrow right
here so this is also a part so for now
we've also only learned to go from a
single pics look like here from a black
pixel to the pattern but now we also
want to learn to go to regrow when
destroyed because that is this you can
see this is modeled after a kind of live
tissue so here you can see the their
parts are cut away and then the these
cells try to regrow so this is I think
initially initially when you just train
them they exhibit some of that property
but not like very satisfying in some
cases so what they do is they train not
only do they use end States like we saw
before but also some of their training
samples are simply the pattern destroyed
of it so as you can see in some of these
samples like these here they in each
sample they kind of cut out part of the
sample and they train the update rules
to regrow that part that gives you that
now gives you the ability to if you
damage too pretty consistently regrow
the pattern as you can see here and they
also train for rotation which is
non-trivial if you have these kind of
pixel based pixel based models but I
jumped up because I want to keep it kind
of short here so the the entire goal of
this is to kind of model at the behavior
of that of natural cells because the
natural cells they don't have an
overarching view they only have the view
of their neighbors right and they are
able to grow in two very complex
structures I invite you to give this a
try the de still don't pop journal is
very cool
it's very interactive you can play
around with it you can reproduce things
in a collab and
yeah shout out to the authors here
Alexander Moore twin self a torrid so
sorry run dot so Evan Nicholson and
Michael 11
yeah that was it for me thanks for
watching and bye bye